queries against very large databases
data sets terabytes and up has brought
us back to the age of the punch card we
submit a batch job and wait patiently
for response this makes exploratory data
analysis impossible by visualizing
samples of the data set and growing
those samples incrementally we can get a
much more responsive experience at the
expense of precision but how will users
respond to emphasize results our data
analysts able to interpret the resultant
confidence bounds we investigate this
question with sample action sample
action is a simulator that allows us to
explore the user experience of immediate
query responses with ever-increasing
sample sizes we are looking at a
database of FAA flight delays the
database is a few million records we
begin by seeing what the average flight
delay is by day of week the system
responds immediately and continues to
retrieve 5,000 additional records per
second after each time step it shows the
average flight delay as it has been
computed so far the blue dots represent
conservative confidence bounds we are
ninety percent sure that the average
delay on a Friday is between seven and
eleven minutes while the average delay
on a Tuesday is between five and nine
minutes while the bounds are still
shrinking we've seen just point five
percent of the data set and that is
enough to let us know to avoid flying on
Fridays if we don't want to be stuck in
the airport we can explore the rates of
convergence for any bar in the chart
here we click on Thursday to see how
quickly it has converged based upon the
number samples so far sample action
allows us to learn about how data
analyst experience and use incremental
queries with changing values on their
own data